[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe paris vous
le savez forcément est une ville connue
et reconnue pour ses atouts touristiques
ses monuments ses grandes avenues ses
magasins mais aussi malheureusement pour
sa pollution qu'elles soient
atmosphérique ou sonores pour tenter
d'améliorer cette situation l'union
européenne finance de nombreux projets
innovants et écologiques dans les
grandes villes à paris justement grâce
au soutien de la commission européenne
la ville vient d'inaugurer de nouveaux
revêtements sur certaines de ses routes
des revêtements qui doivent permettre de
lutter contre le bruit et la chaleur
émise par la circulation nous étions sur
place pour l'inauguration c'est notre
reportage à suivre dès le début de cette
émission nous irons ensuite au parlement
européen pour interviewer un eurodéputé
franciliens l'occasion d'évoquer et les
actualités les plus récents du vieux
continent
elle les sujets ne manquent pas à
quelques semaines désormais du bric
sites et des élections européennes
enfin vous retrouverez également notre
comparatif européen consacré ce mois ci
à la procréation médicalement assistée
galy soir d'une date qui a marqué l
histoire du continent il y à 25 ans
presque tout juste le 1er novembre 1993
le traité de maastricht rentrer en
vigueur
[Musique]
c'est un chiffre impressionnant est
révélateur de la situation écologique
dans les grandes villes européennes 37
millions de citoyens européens sont
aujourd'hui exposées à un niveau de
pollution sonore dangereux pour leur
santé et ce en partie à cause du trafic
routier à paris ses 22 % des habitants
carrément qui sont concernés à cela
s'ajoute la pollution atmosphérique et
une situation qui devient forcément
difficilement respirable pour lutter
contre les effets néfastes de ce
changement climatique la commission
européenne a mis en place depuis 1992
son programme life
objectif soutenir financièrement les
actions en faveur de l'environnement à
paris par exemple la ville travaille
avec plusieurs entreprises est
spécialisée sur le développement d'un
bitume antibruit et anti chaleur
certaines voix comme celle derrière nous
sont déjà équipés de cet asphalte du
futur reportage
paris capitale de la france avec ses
rues et ses grandes places mais aussi et
surtout la capitale-nationale du bruit
et de la pollution
c'est pour tenter de changer cette
réalité que la ville teste depuis
quelques jours de nouveaux enrobés sur
ces routes moins de bruit et moins de
chaleur dégagée le bitume du futur
recouvre 600 m 2 rue parisienne
d'une manière générale les revêtements
qui sont claires on voit plus de
rayonnement vers le ciel et donc
emmagasine moins de chaleur qui
revêtement sombre alors dans le cas ici
on est contraint par le fait que c'est
en enrobé on peut pas peindre la route
tout en blanc parce que ce serait
éblouissant donc on fait un compromis
grâce également à un système permettant
une meilleure rétention de l'eau la
ville et ses partenaires se sont fixé
pour objectif une réduction de la
température ressentie de 3 degrés sur
les axes concernés et une baisse du
bruit de 3 décibels faut savoir qu'une
personne qui est relativement enfin
fortement exposées au bruit dans paris
perd sur sa vie entière de l'ordre d'un
nom de vie en bonne santé du fait du
bruit et donc le fait de diminuer un
petit peu en décibels basso va lui
permettre de mieux dormir de d'être un
petit peu moins gênée même si le bruit
restera quand même conséquent parce
qu'on est en zone urbaine ces
revêtements représente un coût supérieur
à 10% par rapport aux zoos b classique
ils seront évalués pendant trois ans
grâce à différentes installations
techniques
le montant total du projet est évalué à
deux millions trois cent mille euros
financés à plus de 50% par la commission
européenne et son programme life en
faveur de la lutte contre le changement
climatique
on sent on est dans l'ère des solutions
face aux dérèglements climatiques on a
besoin maintenant de concret de
solutions pour cette une un pas
effectivement fait par l'union
européenne on espère que ça va les
inspirer pour faire encore plus sur le
domaine de la transition écologique qui
nécessite une implication de tous les
échelons et pas que des collectivités si
l'efficacité du projet est avérée il
devrait être étendu à d'autres axes
fréquentés de la capitale
paris pourra alors améliorer durablement
le cadre de vie de ses habitants
[Musique]
et pour en savoir un peu plus sur ce
projet là et pas paris et ses enrobé
antibruit anti chaleur nous sommes avec
l'un des responsables du projet olivier
chrétiens bonjour bonjour on peut
affirmer que demain l'ensemble des
routes par exemple parisienne et puis
peut-être européenne puisqu'il ya un
financement européen dans ce projet
seront exploités de la même manière si
c'est un enrobé là qui seront sur les
routes demain française et européenne
écoutez en tous les cas c'est l'objectif
de notre projet alors comme toute
expérimentation
on a toujours des risques on n'est pas
sûr qu'on puisse arriver à avoir le ou
les bons enrobé ou asphalte pour paris
et pour les villes européennes pour
demain mais en tous les cas oui
effectivement on vise à faire évoluer
nos techniques à produire de nouveaux
revêtements qui est l'objectif c'est
vraiment des généralisée et de trouver
le nouveau produit standard on va dire
en standard par au sens non qualitatif
mais vraiment allier à la fois le côté
économique le côté solidité et la
performance
comment on fait pour lutter sur l'effet
chaleur avec six ont enrobé comment
vont-ils pour qu' il ya moins de chaleur
qu'ils soient dégagées avec le trafic
routier
alors là effectivement vous voyez leur
but est tout neuf il est tout noir mais
l'objectif avec le vieillissement de cet
enrobé c'est d'avoir un enrobé plus
clair le gros souci qu'on a un niveau
sanitaire lors des épisodes de canicule
se fait dans les milieux urbains denses
on a pas on a des températures qui ne
laisse pas la nuit
donc ce que je recherche avec des
revêtements plus clair c'est d'avoir des
températures qui peuvent être légèrement
supérieure la journée puisque avec la
réflexion on n'aura pas un effet très
claire la journée mais la nuit on aura
du coup en fin de journée on aura des
revêtements moins chaud qui rendront
moins de chaleur la nuit et donc qu'on
aura on espère avoir vraiment des
différences de températures la nuit et
qui permet du coup à leur manière et
dans leur mesure de lutter un peu contre
le réchauffement climatique alors c'est
pas une lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique là c'est plutôt une
adaptation au changement climatique
alors dernier rapport du giec le dit
bien on a de toute façon même si on fait
un effort intense en termes d'émissions
de co2 on sait qu'on aura des
qu'on a déjà parce que là on est au mois
d'octobre on se promène en tee shirt
on a on a vraiment un problème de
réchauffement à des canicules de plus
nombreuses à venir et on doit s'adapter
à sa merci olivier chrétiens pour toutes
ces précisions et du coup bon courage
pour la suite de vos recherches d votre
projet qui court jusqu'en 2022 on
poursuit désormais est cette émission
sur le plateau de tv 78 dans les
yvelines où vous allez le voir avec
notre nouvel invité le programme life de
la commission européenne est aussi
présent dans le nord du département
précisément là bas la nature s'installe
durablement en plein milieu urbain
[Musique]
pour évoquer à présent l'action de
l'union européenne dans le département
des yvelines nous sommes avec isabelle
chatou sur le plateau de tv 78 bon soir
dans ça vous êtes chef de projet
aménagement et valorisation des espaces
naturels pour le département des
yvelines et vous est notamment
responsable du projet life plus saines
city park dans le nord du département
sur ce que l'on appelle la boucle de
chanteloup ce projet environnemental a
lui aussi bénéficié du coût du soutien
financier du programme life de la
commission européenne c'est un projet
d'envergure est de débuter en 2012
en quelques mots pour le pour le résumé
on peut dire qu'il s'agissait et il
s'agit encore aujourd'hui de
réintroduire la nature sur les bords de
seine sur 1700 hectares précisément où à
peu près c'est ça oui tout à fait
l'objectif du projet est effectivement
c'était de pouvoir dans le cadre de
plusieurs projets d'aménagement
structurants du territoire de la boue de
chanteloup avoir des actions des
aménagements à vocation paysagère et
écologique et d'avoir une transition
écologique entre nos différents projets
d'aménagement
donc il ya une concertation de
l'ensemble des maîtres d ouvrage sur ce
territoire là pour avoir des actions
concertées et coordonnées et raisonnée
qui bénéficie justement de la
valorisation de la commission européenne
la commission européenne et vous le dise
il ya plusieurs collectivités il ya le
département les communautés
d'agglomération les villes
voilà tout à fait il ya la communauté
urbaine grand paris seine et oise ports
de paris les communes qui travaillent
ensemble de concert sur ce projet alors
parmi les projets en question il y a le
plus grand parc naturel du département
un nouveau port des logements un pacte
d'entreprise aussi finalement dans ces
endroits là la nature reprend ses droits
justement pour pour insister là dessus
voilà tout à fait l'objectif c'est
d'avoir des projets qu'ils soient des
projets économiques à vocation
économique à vocation sociale mais
d'avoir aussi une part environnemental
très importante très présente et donc
l'ensemble des projets d'aménagement
permettent d'avoir
une action environnementale assez
importante et conséquente via des
aménagements prévus initialement dans le
cadre des projets et c'est important de
le souligner mais il ya une trame ya une
continuité dans ce projet il n'y a pas
de rupture urbaine
voilà chaque maître d'ouvragé a pensé
son projet d'aménagement en concertation
entre guillemets avec le voisin est donc
ce qui nous permet d'avoir une
continuité entre les différents projets
on s'arrête pas juste à l'âtre périmètre
foncier en se disant le le voisin lui
fera son propre projet dans son coin
s'étaient pas l'objectif l'idée c'était
d'avoir tout le monde autour de la table
qui se concertent se coordonnent il ya
déjà un projet qui est une réalité
concrète pour les habitants du nord du
département c'est le parc du peuple de
l'herbe
un nom qui parle de lui-même situé lui
aussi en bord de seine c'est un parc
mais pas uniquement il ya aussi un rôle
de pédagogie sur la biodiversité le parc
départemental du peuple de l'herbe
c'est effectivement un aménagement sur
113 hectares en bord de seine 2 et en
aménager revalorisée avec des
aménagements paysagers et écologique
puisqu'on est sur un espace naturel
sensible du département c'est notre
vocation
mais il ya également un grand volet
d'accueil et d'ouverture au public avec
de la pédagogie à l'environnement c'est
un lieu de loisirs de détente qui
profite à tout le monde
alors au delà du parc du peuple de
l'herbe on peut aussi citer les qu'au
port l'écopôle les autres noms sont vous
lisez moi la nouvelle centralité voilà
donc ce sont des projets qui en fait
juste le parc du peuple de l'herbe et
donc
des projets d'aménagement donc sur un
plus long terme puisque voilà il faut un
petit peu de temps pour créer des
logements et est un des créations
d'entreprises
donc là le projet life que cet hiver qui
a permis d'apporter une première
dynamique une première impulsion puis le
tout va ce phase est encore sur
plusieurs années j'allais vous demandez
où justement le rôle de ce financement
européen un peu plus de 1 million 700
mille euros au delà de l'apport
financier qui est toujours intéressant
et important qu'est ce que ça apporte
d'avoir le soutien de l'union européenne
ça apporte de la légitimité peut-être
vous allez limiter ça valorise vraiment
les projets d'aménagement on est reconnu
par rapport à l'amour la politique menée
par la commission européenne
ça valorise notre projet d'aménagement
et ça nous apporte un peu de un peu de
poids merci isabelle chats tous d'être
venus sur ce plateau et pour vos
réponses
l'europe justement on va continuer d'en
parler avec l'interview d'un eurodéputé
franciliens au parlement européen de
strasbourg dans quelques instants
mais avant faisons une pause sur
l'histoire du vieux continent il ya 25
ans presque tout juste le 1er novembre
1993 le traité de maastricht rentrer en
vigueur celui ci a bouleversé l'histoire
du continent
c'est ce que nous détaille justement
philippe le guen coordinateur adjoint
pour le parlement européen de la maison
jean monnet basée à bazoches sur guyonne
dans les yvelines
alors ce traité de maastricht il est
important parce que c'est le premier est
la première révision des traités
d'après justement la la la la fin du mur
de berlin et donc de là dans la nouvelle
géographie de l'europe et donc il
annonce des évolutions importantes
l'union économique et monétaire qui
jette les bases pour lancer la monnaie
unique
ils l'ont ils annoncent la politique
européenne de défense et de sécurité qui
jusqu'à présent n'était pas du tout un
sujet un volet traités par là par les
instances de communes de l'union
européenne
il a il change aussi le nom de
communauté européenne en union
européenne donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a commencé à parler de l'union et
il
il modifie aussi à certains noms de deux
domaines de de prise de décision et donc
c'est quand même un moment fondamental
dans l'histoire de l'est de l'évolution
des traités il y en a eu d'autres par la
suite mais on se réfère souvent au
traité de maastricht comme étant celui
qui a quand même apporté beaucoup de
beaucoup de changements
alors en particulier sur le plan de la
monnaie puisque là on commence vraiment
à préparer l'union monétaire alors on
disait l'union économique et monétaire
on sait que le volet économique
malheureusement a pris du retard pour le
moins et n'est toujours pas vraiment en
application mais en tout cas l'union
monétaire est lancée à partir de
maastricht et et bien ça débouchera
quelques années plus tard à
l'introduction de l'euro
[Musique]
désormais nous sommes au parlement
européen de strasbourg pour poursuivre
cette émission nous sommes en compagnie
de l'eurodéputé francilien jean marie
cavada président du mouvement
générations citoyens aimant et membre du
groupe aele 2e ici au parlement le
député centriste nous allons faire un
tour de l'actualité européenne à
commencer par le sujet brûlant
cette semaine c'est l'italie avec ces
tensions autour de son budget largement
au dessus des prévisions initiales un
déficit de 2 4% contre 0 28 % promis par
l'ancien gouvernement la commission a
retoqué clairement ce budget c'est une
première en europe
elle laisse trois semaines à l'italie
pour en proposer un nouveau est ce que
cette cette première c'est dangereux
pour l'union européenne c'est clairement
une situation assez dangereuse si
l'italie se cabre et si la commission
après une première rafale de décision
ne regarde pas les conditions générales
de cette affaire de quoi je veux parler
les les gens qui sont actuellement au
pouvoir
salvini d'une part di maio d'autre part
sont des gens qui ont fait des promesses
électorales exorbitantes
il faut le dire et notamment
l'augmentation de pratiquement 20 % des
salaires notamment du salaire minimum et
des et des bas salaires ce qui est
infaisable
un pays ne peut pas de dépenser plus
qu'il ne produit de richesse sinon
évidemment il court à la catastrophe
mais pourquoi je dis ça parce que les
italiens la population italienne elle
n'est pas anti européenne elle veut
rester dans l'europe elle veut même
selon des sondages récents rester dans
l'euro d'ailleurs vaisselle mais c'est
au gouvernement italien a dit qu'il
n'était pas sûr question d'une sortie
d'italie de la rode nous ont pris ils
ont pris leurs précautions pour jalonner
leur colère mais il ya un deuxième sujet
qui consécutive du premier pourquoi ces
gens là qui sont quand même un peu
improbable sont ils arrivés au pouvoir
parce que l'europe
les pays membres de l'europe ce n'est
pas bruxelles qu'irresponsable ceni pays
membres de l'union n'ont pas fait leur
travail de solidarité vis-à-vis des
questions migratoires on les a laissé de
mot avec ça alors il faut pas venir
s'étonner après que la question ce soit
celle de la colère sur cette question du
budget ce que vous pensez que la
commission européenne a intérêt à être
dur sur ce sujet ou alors à nouer un
dialogue quand même assez conciliant
avec avec l'italie et puis du coup les
italiens aussi pieux ce sont les
italiens qui ne vous le fais pas dire
vous me l'enlever de la bouche je pense
que tout le monde après un premier
rendez vous chacun montre ses muscles
veut pas se mettre autour de la table et
commencer à discuter un peu sérieusement
qui va faire une concession dans sur
quels sujets qui répondra par une
concession sur quel autre sujet c'est
très dangereux parce que l'italie c'est
pas la grèce
en traîneau pour une économie majeure
c'est une des trois économies les plus
importantes origines même et si jamais
il y avait une secousse monétaire et
financière en italie je pense que là ce
serait un autre sport que celui que nous
a obligés à faire la grève donc c'est
ultra dangereux c'est pourquoi je pense
qu'il y aura négociation je le souhaite
en tout cas
comment vous percevez les critiques et
notamment cet argument de déficit
démocratique en la commission européenne
retoque un budget d'un gouvernement élu
et qui finalement respecte ses promesses
et du coup la commission européenne
seraient contre cette démocratie là je
ne comprends pas traître mot de cette
histoire et je trouve que tout ça est
d'une profonde démagogie assorti de
quelques mensonges c'est ce qu'on entend
souvent
matteo salvini je suis bien d'accord
mais oui mais ça c'est de ces du wishful
thinking comme on dit en mauvais
français c'est à dire c'est une façon
d'ameuter les foules pour se décharger
des responsabilités parce que quelle est
la responsabilité primordiale dans cette
affaire c'est les positions que c'est
populiste comme on les appelle une façon
un peu facile ont pris dans la campagne
électorale en promettant la lune à midi
elles soleil à minuit les augmentations
de salaire de 20% et tout un tas
d'autres choses
il fallait être un peu plus prudent et
se comporter en homme d'état et il faut
faire attention les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les tiennent dans le monde
comment dirais-je exigeant dans lequel
nous vivons et puis deuxièmement
personne n'est obligé l'italie a signé
les traités
c'est l'état italien qui de lui même et
avec l'accord de sa population à signer
les traités européens et qui font de
l'italie un des membres ce totalement
fondamentaux il faut donc fondateur 1157
de l'union donc il faut respecter les
traités donc un peu de calme et un peu
de grandeur ça fera du bien à tout le
monde
plus largement les tensions autour de
l'italie avec ce
hoover nouveau gouvernement qualifié de
populiste même si visiblement vous
n'aimez pas trop ça veut rien dire
surtout salir mais beaucoup de gens dans
ce paquet là ils y allaient aussi les
oraux critique eurosceptiques on ne sait
pas comment les appareils eurosceptique
il ya des pro européens même s'ils ne
partagent pas tous de la politique
européenne actuelle ce qui est mon cas
d'ailleurs il ya les anti européens qui
se masque n'y a rien et pro pour vous
avez bien entendu vous le verrez dans la
prochaine mandature ici d'ailleurs qui
commence justement sa lettre pétition
lui mais à partir de mai 2010 neuf vous
le verrez ça va se diviser comme ça tout
le monde prédit une victoire en tout cas
une augmentation des voix dès les
antieuropéens du coup si je reprends
votre expression est ce que il faut se
faire à cette idée jean marie cavada ou
est-ce qu à sept mois des élections
sinon on peut encore inverser le cours
des choses je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
je ne me hasarderai pas à faire une
prédiction ce que je veux ce que je veux
souligner c'est que vu de mon point de
vue il ya deux situations extrêmement
dangereuses
il ya l'allemagne où un député sur cinq
fait partie de la sève des alternatives
et für deutschland dont la direction est
native pour une nouvelle allemagne pour
une nouvelle dont la direction est
totalement inspiré des nazis je dis pas
les électeurs jeudi la direction de
monsieur groupe quelqu'un qui adore
hitler qui a beaucoup deep fait pour sa
promotion que c'était un bien brave
homme à feindre est une horreur absolue
de négationnisme de l'histoire et en
allemagne maintenant alors que
l'allemagne avait été jusqu'à présent
existe vraiment historique du nazisme
qui est un crime contre leur enclave
élèves d épuiser un mouvement en europe
des forces des forces anti européenne
dont on pourrait dire que monsieur urban
le leader en droit était de lui lâcher
deux heures oui oui la tête de gondole
s'amènera le prochain parlement à mon
avis à des coalitions des pro-européens
beaucoup plus nette que celle qui ont
lieu en ce moment avec beaucoup moins
d'états d'âme pour travailler ensemble à
l' inflexion de la politique européenne
et c'est vrai qu'il ya besoin maintenant
d'une inflexion la vérité c'est que
l'europe est au milieu du gué pour une
raison simple c'est pas parce qu'il ya
trop d'europe et notamment il ya trop de
renseignements fait le problème de
l'europe est ce que c'est
c'est juste un marché libérale
économique et il n'y a pas de juste
trop d'europe de normes et de
technocratie c'est sans doute vrai
encore qu'il ya du bon dans ce qui a été
décidé mais il y en a pas assez sur le
régalien le régalien c'est quoi c'est ce
qu'un pays tout seul n'a pas les moyens
de faire donc il faut se regrouper à
plusieurs une armée aux dépens des
européens
lala lala com dh de contrôle des
frontières la lutte contre le crime
international un tiers de l'europe
la transition énergétique ça c'est du
régalien le reste il faut laisser les
états faire s'en mêler jean marie cavada
vous êtes eurodéputé depuis 2004 c'était
l'époque où l'union européenne
s'élargissent et à l'est désormais un
pays membres souhaitent la quitter la
grande bretagne
on a du mal à être optimiste aujourd'hui
pour le vieux continent même si parfois
aussi force
comment vous expliquer un tel
basculement en 15 ans est ce que c'est
la faute de l'union européenne qui n'a
pas su prouver son utilité aux yeux des
européens ce que c'est les européens
peut-être trop trop gâtés qui n'arrive
pas percevoir la chance qu'ils ont de
vivre ainsi deux choses qu'il faut
apercevrez avec beaucoup de réalisme
la première c'est que l'union européenne
c'est à dire les états membres à
bruxelles par la commission pas le
parlement les patrons mes patrons les
états membres se sont eux les patrons
les chefs de gouvernement pour vous moi
et n'importe quel endroit italien
finlandais sont élus ce sont ceux là qui
ont freiné la politique européenne comme
diaz communautaire pour les principales
questions
les britanniques qui sortent de
maintenance et leurs gouvernements
successifs qui se sont opposés à la
construction politique du régalien dont
je parle alors qu'on sait très bien
qu'on ne peut pas tout seul un pays tout
ça ne peut pas ce sont eux qui en qui se
sont opposés c'est pourquoi moi je ne
vais pas pleurer sur le départ de la
grande bretagne puisque le tout c'est
que ce soit une négociation qui soit à
l'intérêt respectifs de chacun des pays
et notamment l'union 1 mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui que la politique du mensonge
en grande bretagne a fait des malheureux
puisque le pouvoir d'achat en grande
bretagne a déjà baissé de 8 à 10%
et quand le pouvoir d'achat baisse c'est
pas les riches qu'ils qui pleure c'est
les pauvres qui sont en difficulté voilà
le résultat du mensonge que monsieur
faral johnson les britanniques qui ont
menti aux électeurs ont apportée
je suis stupéfait d'ailleurs que les
gens les considèrent encore vous serez
candidat en 2019 alors c'est une très
bonne question la réponse en janvier
avant de se quitter intéressons-nous un
dernier sujet la procréation médicale
médicalement assistée la pm a refait
surface en france avec la révision des
lois de bioéthique le gouvernement est
favorable à son élargissement aux
couples de femmes et aux femmes seules
qu'en est-il dans le reste de l'union
européenne ont fait le point avec
olivier jeunes ouest le responsable du
centre europe direct à saint germain en
laye alors la pma c'est ce qu'on appelle
la procréation médicalement assistée
donc c'est à dire c'est l'ensemble des
techniques qu'on utilise afin de
on va dire afin de créer
artificiellement entre eux entre
guillemets un embryon
donc voilà c'est l'ensemble des
techniques médicales qui sont utilisés
et nous en france on connaît
particulièrement ce qu'on appelle la
fécondation in vitro la pma mme en
europe en fait ton âme
tout dépend de la législation du pays
parce que on a des spécificités on a
certains pays comme la france qui
autorise par exemple la pma uniquement
pour les couples hétérosexuels
on a d'autres pays qui autorisent la pma
pour les personnes seules pour les
femmes célibataires ou les couples
homosexuels
c'est notamment le cas par exemple en
belgique au danemark ou en espagne on a
aussi des pays où par exemple on n'a pas
de législation concernant l'après mal
c'est notamment le cas de la roumanie où
là on va dire que c'est un peu une sorte
de vide juridique
alors après en fonction des législations
dans les pays de 6 et plus ou moins
ouvert on peut avoir
on peut avoir différents critères par
exemple l'âge maximum dépend
essentiellement du pays
en grèce et en estonie l'âge maximal
pour bénéficier d'une pma et de 50 ans
si on prend le danemark et l'irlande
cet âge maximum est de 45 ans on a aussi
certains pays où il n'ya pas de limite
d'âge maximum le maximum pour bénéficier
d'une pma et notamment c'est le cas par
exemple de l'autriche ou de chypre et
jean marie cavada quelle est votre
position à vous sur un tel sujet ce
qu'il faut autoriser la pma à toutes les
femmes en france puisque vous êtes
favorable à ça je suis favorable à la
pma parce que le monde moderne a montré
très clairement que l'opinion et les
lois étaient majoritairement je dis pas
tout le monde était majoritairement
favorables la désunion qui sortent de
l'union classique hommes femmes et par
conséquent dans ces conditions il faut
que le droit que la possibilité d'avoir
un enfant existe même il faut que ce
soit très encadrée parce que le commerce
du ventre est une abomination et c'est
là où est toute la difficulté
merci beaucoup pour vos réponses sont
mariés à quercy à notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
franciliens membres du parti s'y
qualifient de centristes à elle des
oeufs et président du mouvement
générations citoyens merci aussi aux
équipes du parlement pour la réalisation
de cet entretien c'est la fin de ce set
8 europe on se retrouve à la
du mois de novembre pour un nouveau
numéro 10 il avoue retrouver cette
émission en replay sur tv 78 points
comme ou l'application tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le